[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
what [__] liar
oh man this is the best that manga can
run in the Democratic party it's RFK Jr
literally he's the manga candidate in
the Democratic party trying to shake
things up trying to get rid of Joe Biden
because they're terrified of Joe Biden
the Republicans are absolutely terrified
of dark Brandon at this point so much so
that they're willing to invite RFK Jr to
a a sham house Committee hearing on
weaponization of government
and he's perjuring himself time and time
again
clearly in his own words he's been
anti-semitic and anti-vaxx and racist in
his own [__] words and recordings
that he said no one like well I mean
maybe someone held a gun to his head
made him say this [__] I don't know it's
possible it's possible that they have
something on him and that's why he's
doing what he's doing I don't know his
motivation but he certainly is ant time
backs he certainly is anti-Semitic and
he certainly has said racist [__]
period
and Debbie Wasserman Schultz I just
watched a few clips of Debbie Wasserman
Schultz absolutely tearing him to shreds
over the lies and that he's presenting
in front of the committee under oath
trying to fight for time
literally he's talking over Debbie
Wasserman Schultz listen RFK Jr is not a
serious person he's not
just because his last name is Kennedy
and he's done a lot for climate change
as an activist does not make him a
serious person if you think if you think
every single activist in this country is
a serious person you are mistaken
he's not a serious person and you can
tell that in his contempt for the rules
in the Committee hearing even Jim Jordan
has to award time back to Debbie
Wasserman Schultz because RFK Jr won't
shut his [__] mouth
and the reason why is because he's
trying to defend his misinformation he's
trying to defend his lies and he's
trying to lie by doing it
this is the best they have folks the
best they got
this is their best chance to beat Joe
Biden
other than the the No Labels Joe manchin
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense
they are terrified that Donald Trump is
going to be the nominee and is going to
lose they know it
they know it
it is clear and if you don't see this if
you don't see what RFK Jr is about why
he is trying to become on the Democratic
ticket he won't win one delegate trust
me period not one not one
and then for Dennis kucinich to sit
behind him and smile and grin what [__]
that guy too [__] him too
they are not Democrats they are Maga
I don't give a [__] what party they've
been in their whole life that doesn't
make you not Maga
you are [__] fascist
get with the program
it's not rocket science what is going on
in front of your eyes
they know they can't beat Joe Biden on
his record they know he's gonna run laps
around them
without even lifting a [__] finger
Marjorie Taylor green proved that to us
in the Joe Biden ad that I played
yesterday where she got on stage and
listed off Joe Biden's accomplishments
as if the American people doesn't want
that [__]
they want education yes yeah they want
education for their children they
certainly do
and they like the public education that
is the institution in our country that
we've worked
over a century to develop
is it perfect no but that's what they
want
Health Care
helping rule poverty
what the [__] is gonna affect more Trump
voters
than to try to lift rural areas out of
poverty
think about it
and she's saying it as if it's a bad
thing
and because it is such a shitty message
the Democrats and Joe Biden are able to
just play her words
as an ad for them
they know they're going to lose
they know the chips are stacked against
them
they know they have lost the culture
wars why do you think Barbie is gonna be
a huge movie I haven't seen it yet Gabe
Sanchez says it's a great movie and now
I gotta go see the [__] because
he also says that Republicans hate it
and he knows why and again once you see
it you'll know why [__] I gotta go watch
this [__] movie
I I have an obligation as a commentator
[Laughter]
I had to listen to the Jason Aldean song
I I might as well go watch the Barbie
movie
but they've lost the culture War folks
they've lost what do you think all the
flailing is about what do you think all
the bitching is about
what do you think all the bigotry is
about why do you think they're trying to
legislate people out of existence
because they've lost
they've lost
the majority of the country does not
believe their [__] garbage they don't
believe that vaccines kill you and that
they're they're horrible and bad and
they don't want to read debate covid
this country does not want to go back
three years ago and rehash what happened
during covid they don't
Ron DeSantis you [__] fool RFK Jr you
[__] fool
they don't want to do that
they don't
and they're not going to
this country is not going to have
another [__] coveted debate they're
just not
and the only reason why they're dragging
things like covet and wokism
and whining and bitching about how
unfair it is that the justice department
is Prosecuting the orange Mussolini
Jesus for his crimes
no one wants to hear that [__]
trust me on this
they know they're going to lose
this is what the RFK sitting in front of
the weaponization Committee hearing
today and lying his [__] ass off in
front of the American people what a joke
this is the best they got
this is it the best they got
to try to get Trump elected is RFK Jr
and Joe manchin
good luck [__] good luck keep
going take your shovel and keep digging
step on every single one of those rakes
you're throwing down
and we should politicize every single
moment
every single little moment yesterday
Marjorie Taylor green holds up Hunter
Biden born in a public hearing on public
TV and they're like oh porn's bad kids
shouldn't see porn we shouldn't show
porn and she's like look at this [__]
porn hey look at the porn look at a big
old dick on Hunter oh man he's got a
huge [__] look tell me that this guy's
got a huge [__] and he posted it in his
laptop and I stole it and I put it here
right here uh-huh see he's got a big old
dick
what the [__] does that have to do
with corruption
Marjorie Taylor green cheated on her
husband with some kind of Fitness
[__] Guru at her gym
probably [__] him in the gym
yeah that's right what do you want from
me what do you want for she's the one
obsessed with dick
obsessed with Hunter's bit dick big huge
hog dick
well I can't I don't get to [__]
write this stuff
she held up pictures of Hunter Biden
having sex
in a public Committee hearing yesterday
and Fox News is like yeah air that [__]
man hell yeah all the while they're like
we can't let our children see the statue
of David oh my God it shows a little
penis on the Statue of David it's
pornography we're we're gonna make our
children gay or some stupid [__]
this this is the real America First Nazi
party and I am sick and tired of people
light footing around it they are [__]
Nazis
they do not they do not
say do as I say not as I do
Marjorie Taylor green
RFK Jr you piece of [__] trash
Jim Jordan oh my God James Comer
you couldn't scrape more of the bottom
of the barrel here
and this is their great defense this is
their great their great offense to get
Trump elected good
bring it I'm excited about it
and you should be too
you should be absolutely elated that
these are the people that they're
putting out front to try to get Trump to
win they're [__] losers is what they
are degenerates and losers
my guess is that Marjorie Taylor green
probably won't even win her seat back
next time I know it sounds crazy but
she's probably gonna get primary and get
crushed
because she's such a [__] ding-a-ling
no pun intended I mean you know she
likes hunters and sex gurus
dingalings hey [__] nope nope look at
me I'm just telling you the truth
I'm getting all pissed off cause I say
the truth
I tell you
but this is where we're at in American
politics
all the while all the while oh my god
did you see did you see what's his name
what's the guy who played Jesus
on The Passion of Christ Henry what the
f is this what's his name this [__]
guy
John he's on Fox this morning saying
that that he's Jesus
and Trump is Moses I already can tell
that a bunch of Maga idiots online
they're gonna already have a bunch of AI
that shows
this guy is Jesus and Trump is Moses I
can already see it and they're gonna
believe it they're like oh yeah that
sounds about right
Trump is Moses
oh man and you're trying to convince me
that it's not a cult get the [__] out of
here I've been telling you for months
and I'm gonna keep telling you until
he's nominated
that Trump is going to be nominated and
if you don't know if you don't if you
don't think he is then you do not know
how Cults work
and the justice department isn't going
to save you from Trump being nominated
stop acting like the justice department
is going to save us from this fool it is
us we are the jury we get to decide we
are going to crush them next November
that is what they're scared of that's
why they have RFK in this Committee
hearing just saying crazy ass [__] I
guarantee you I guarantee you by the end
of the day there's going to be dozens of
Republicans in front of microphones
saying well this crazy lunatic is a
Democrat he's not a republican no he's
Maga
he's Maca I don't give a [__] what party
he thinks he's in he ain't in the
Democratic party he's not nope no way no
how
and if you're unaware how Democratic
primaries work if you're unaware
the the incumbent president does not
have to debate anybody that is that is
how it works I don't care if you don't
[__] like it he doesn't have to
debate him and he's going to tell him to
get [__] and after today there's even
more reason for Joe Biden to tell RFK to
[__] off and we're not debating I'm not
going to debate someone who goes in
front of Congress and lies his ass off
about [__] that he said on camera
get the [__] out of here I'm not
debating this [__] lying piece of
[__]
he RFK Jr just gave every reason why Joe
Biden does not have to debate him today
he doesn't have to anyways but now he
really doesn't have to
and oh by the way there's a thing in the
Democratic primary called super
delegates remember the Bernie supporters
are really pissed off about him you
remember this they were really pissed
off about super delegates that's why Joe
Biden is going to be the nominee that's
why he doesn't have to debate that's why
it's stupid to even talk about anyone
but Joe Biden be in the Democratic
nominee this is dumb stupid [__] and
it's a waste of breath to have to
[__] argue with this with people
especially people on the left who claim
to know about elections who claim to
know how [__] how [__] midterm
excuse me primaries work for an
incumbent president
if you claim that you know and you don't
know that Joe Biden is going to be the
[__] nominee by default because he's
in the incumbent Democratic president
you are lying
either that or you're a dumb
[__] sorry you may be on the
left but you're a dumb [__]
if you if you are spreading the why that
Joe Biden has to debate and he oh hey
Joe badden and hurricane debate debate
debate no he does not have to do that
that is not a thing he will be the
nominee 100 with the super delegates
know your [__] go look it up if you
don't if you need help we can try to
spell it for you okay
and if you really want to see context of
super delegates
and an extensive reporting of super
delegates and how they [__] work go
look at the 2016 election just type in
in the Google machine
2016 Democratic super delegates Bernie
Hillary type that [__] in you'll get all
kinds of [__] articles on how this
[__] works and why Bernie who is not a
Democrat was pissed off that Democrats
gave their super delegates to Hillary
because she is a Democrat
use your [__] heads
when you're doing this [__]
so all of you out there yelling and
screaming uh your bad it's not good
enough
he's old blah blah blah shut the [__] up
yeah I'm telling I don't give a [__] if
you're in my audience enough of the
nonsense enough of the lies and the
misinformation because what you're
saying what you're perpetrating is a lie
and misinformation I don't care if you
don't want Joe Biden I don't give a [__]
that is who you got we voted him in
remember this 2020 he became the
president the Democratic president
I don't know if you were around I don't
know if you remember that one it's the
one where Donald Trump tried to
overthrow our government tried to
overthrow our [__] vote
with the violent Insurrection on January
6th you remember that
were you here for that one huh we voted
Joe Biden in when you do that you vote
them in for two two terms to run on two
terms that's what you do
in this country because they only get
two terms
and honestly we should we should change
the Constitution this is my feeling we
should change the Constitution where a a
person can only run for president twice
that's it
we wouldn't have Joe Biden as a
president but [__] it that is what we
need to do it's enough of this [__]
where these people perpetually run over
and over and over and over for their
entire lives make an entire career and a
running for president it's dumb as dog
[__]
Andrew Yang's gonna do it I'm sure rfk's
gonna continue to do this stupid [__]
and on and on it will go with these dumb
[__] these unserious people
running for president of the United
States
and if we limit to how many times you
can actually run then maybe maybe just
maybe we'll get serious people running
not running so you can [__]
elevate your social media influence so
that you can perpetrate misinformation
RFK Jr
you [__] piece of trash
sorry kind of went up on a tangent there
yeah we got a great show for you today
it's a gonna be a great show
uh not only not only do I have a lot of
video to show you uh but we have Fred
Wellman on Fred Wellman is a great great
commentary and and he's an audience
favorite you guys loved when we had him
on the last time so we got Fred back
today Fred Wellman is back today we also
I'm hoping I'm hoping we can connect
with major Ojeda today after Fred leaves
us I think we're gonna get major Ojeda
Richard ogetta on the on the podcast
today our timing he's got a short window
so I'm hoping we can talk to Fred and
major today on the podcast two two
audience favorites
um so I'm hoping that's it we got a lot
of new names in the chat today uh the
moderators are telling me there's a lot
of new people here so don't forget while
you're here do not forget to subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast you're
gonna You're Gonna Wanna hit the like
button You're Gonna Wanna hit the
Subscribe button because we are here
every single weekday that's right if
you're a new audience member we do this
show Monday through Friday two full
hours every single weekday I yell and
scream live into the microphone just
like I've been doing
so if you love me or you love to hate me
at this point go ahead and hit that
subscribe button don't forget to hit the
like button as well or the dislike
button I don't give a [__] if you don't
like me [__] hit the thumbs down let's
do it as long as you engage that's all
we care about and you can watch this
show not just on YouTube you can also
watch it on Facebook live go to at the
Tony Michaels if you still have a
Facebook account
over there on the meta universe
so go to at the Tony Michaels that's at
the Tony Michaels on Facebook you can
also watch us on Twitch we stream to
Twitch it's free to follow us on Twitch
go to twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels
and oh by the way
for all the audience members that have
an Amazon Prime account tied to their
Twitch account don't forget to
resubscribe this month
I I know I say that all the time but I
gotta keep reminding because you got to
subscribe every single month and if you
want to tie your Amazon Prime account
where you get a free subscription to a
Twitch account with your Amazon gaming
you can go to thetonymichaels.com that's
thetonymichaels.com you can find the
directions there it's the fourth link
down it says link Amazon and twitch so
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account give us that one brief
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account and we get a couple bucks
of Amazon's money each month so go to
twitch.tv Tony Michaels if you need the
directions on how to do that just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com don't forget it to visit
our merch store way while you're there
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty store not
the Tony michaels.com you can find these
t-shirts at store not the Tony
michaels.com or you can just go to the
Tony michaels.com hit the merch store
link and you can find us all the links
all the everywhere's threads Instagram
the books of face Twitter all the links
are over there on the Tony michaels.com
so don't forget to visit oh we're there
I'm glad to have all the new audience
members I don't know how many are new
today who's new today hell I'll give you
a shout out if you're new today
who's new today in the chat I'm excited
to have newcomers to the show I don't
know if you're here to see Fred if
you're here to see major but I'm excited
that you're here
if you're new someone says love that
shirt oh someone oh let's see what do we
got here
hey Tony I'm not new Allison good
morning Allison good morning good
morning I'm glad to have you here rather
you're new or you've been here for
months and years as MJ has been here for
months and years I'm glad to have you
here John Riley on YouTube says I'm new
good morning John welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast again do not forget to
hit the Subscribe button down below
you're not going to want to miss a
single one of these [__] trust
me ask the audience member ask the chat
how how how hard it is if you miss one
of these bastards you do not want to
miss this I'm telling you this is the
greatest show on Earth as far as
politics go
um Kim says I am new good morning Kim
Welcome welcome welcome
Carrie says I'm old as [__] I don't know
if that means you're an old audience I
know you've been here for a while
garyvee I don't know if that means
you're an old audience member or if
you're just old I'm not really sure I
feel like I'm getting old
oh Kirk here is new to the chat welcome
Kurt to the chat I'm glad that you we
got newcomers here in the chat and
everyone's having fun this is one of the
most engaged Chats on the planet whether
you're on the YouTube channel you're on
Twitch or you're on Facebook
the Tony Michaels podcast is where it's
at in politics
it just is it just is
it just is and we're gonna I'm telling
you uh Penny says Tony's rants are
legendary yeah so here's how it works if
you're new I do an a block and I do a
full rant the first 30 minutes right
that's what I do and whatever the
stories of the day are I let loose on
these [__] every single day the
first 30 minutes and then what we do is
we go to a quick commercial break we go
to a quick break we come back we go
through videos we have guests we have
Gabe Sanchez my great co-host comes on
he he does a song and dance you're gonna
love his song and dance and you know
what I've got a great music video to
show you today too at some point don't
let me forget that Tennessee Brando has
a brand new music a brand new song out
it's way better than the Jason Aldean
song way better
way better
um and it describes how these moglodytes
can't give can't can't get Hunter off
their brain they just can't
they can't
some people are saying they're part of
the furniture here that's right
part of the furniture I like that
I like that all right let's go to a
break let's show the newbies in the chat
what the break is like let's go to break
when we come back we're gonna have Fred
Wellman very soon very soon don't don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this quick break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show we got a lot of
newcomers in the chat
I'm excited today
we're gonna I think we're on two
yesterday
I think we're gonna say I got one get
guest waiting in the wings
[Music]
kill him well he had him on I don't know
it was a couple weeks ago I think I
think it was a couple weeks ago and for
a Fred Wellman on and everyone's like
hey you got a Fred back you gotta Fred
back so guess what today we have Fred
back Fred Wellman welcome back to the
Tony Michaels podcast the famous the
Tony Michaels podcast I'm glad to see
you my friend how are you yeah good to
be back brother nice to be uh wanted
people want to return I guess yeah
that's that happens in the chat when I
when I uh the other day well what
happened is we have bonehead of the week
on Friday it's a special segment that we
do the audience votes on who is the
bonehead of the week I think I think
Marge has won the last three weeks I'd
love to put her on this week for putting
porn in the Committee hearing I don't
know though I'm I think I'm gonna ban
her from the bonehead because she always
wins she just runs away with it it's not
even fair she's a she's the biggest
bonehead I've ever seen that for sure
but here's the thing here's the thing is
that I needed a co-host and your name
came up in the chat as one of the
co-hosts but I I ended up I ended up
tapping Ray
yeah I tapped her and she came last week
before I could get to Fred Wellman on
the list but I decided you know what I'm
gonna invite Fred back on the show that
because the audience wanted Fred so I
was like okay let's get Fred back on the
show you know what's crazy is I think it
was last week or the beginning this week
when I invited you on and I was like
let's talk about ndaa and there's been
so much [__] it feels like the ndaa is
like six years ago doesn't it no I know
I did a video for Midas tux he just
posted it now it's like old history it's
like you know the the flood of crazy we
know bannon's rule the flood zone was
[__] right that's right well I I mean I
think I think that's what some of these
uh this weaponization stuff is
um now yesterday we saw that Marjorie
Taylor green was absolutely obsessed
with Hunter Biden's hog right I mean
they can't get their they can't get
Hunter Biden's pornography that he makes
on his laptop that they stole they can't
get it out of their brains but today now
we have RFK Jr which is absolutely just
a ridiculous notion that this guy would
anybody be anywhere near a presidential
nomination let alone a debate speech and
and he's proven it today I actually
think that this is a good thing and I
don't know why Republicans keep throwing
these rakes to step on you know they
keep throwing them down in front of
themselves but having RFK Jr under oath
in this hearing where Debbie Wasserman
Schultz did one of the best jobs and we
can show that clip here in a second
where she absolutely she's like look I'm
reading from the [__] transcript of
what you said and he's like no that's
not what I said like yes it is and it
just proves that he's not a serious
person right I mean we want RFK Jr to
some degree because he's been such a a a
great activist in climate change in
years past we want him to be a serious
person but just because you're an
activist and your name is Kennedy
doesn't make you a serious person and it
doesn't mean that you're going to be a
Presidential nominee have you watched
some of the clips this morning of this
team yeah I've been following the whole
thing it's just train wreck you know and
so what would give us your take on it
well first of all he's invited by the
Republican majority right so as a
Democrat candidate let's just start
there like why why does the Maga crowd
want RFK Jr in front of them uh if he's
supposedly a democratic nominee for
president so the the fact that they're
being he's being paraded about our U.S
capital by Republicans not Democrats
tells you all you need to know about why
he's in the Democratic campaign for
president so starting with the entire
facetious you know the whole setup of
this thing is why it's so [__]
ridiculous but then you get into what
the crazy stuff he says and he got taken
apart pretty well like Maya Wiley was
there she's wonderful taken apart for
you know my I talked about
um you know what New York was like
during the covet I was there I ran I ran
a coveted field Hospital in New York
City during the height of the pandemic
when we were stacking bodies and and
refrigerated trucks the streets why the
whole city was shot down because people
were dying I mean I saw people enter our
Hospital uh come out you know four to
five days later or emaciated you know
gray hair you know it's a very deadly
disease and anyone out there saying
people shouldn't get vaccinated people
shouldn't uh you know defend themselves
from this disease it's just it's just
it's [__] ridiculous so I I started I
I dismiss everything he says because the
fact he's pretending to run for the
Democratic nomination when it's just
it's just it's ass perturbing Steve
Bannon and Roger Stone this is a classic
Roger Stone maneuver Roger Stone's done
this for years they field fake
candidates with faint names if you
follow Florida politics you see it all
the time but they'll run a guy with a
with a name similar to another candidate
and just put him on the ballot as a sock
puppet peel off five six percent of the
vote for their candidate wins it's
exactly doing it's a famous name he's a
candy Oh Kennedy Kennedy Kennedy anybody
who talks about Kennedy in his poll
numbers is because his name's [__]
Kennedy that's it and nobody knows who
he is so it's just um a ridiculous it
goes to the entire clown show that is
the Republican
um you know caucus right now in the
house you know and it's it's like um
Aeros Wallace said at my show last week
that the Republicans have become the
party of non-consensual nudes uh I was
outraged I mean I I actually just lost
my [__] to be honest yesterday about
Margarita green showing those pictures
because
every laughs that off because we become
so immune to the insanity but this is
the United States House of
Representatives this is our people's
house and a member of Congress decided
to put print out with tax dollars the UN
you know a private citizen because in
the end he's a private citizen a private
citizens
stolen
well it's a revenge porn is what it is
she did revenge porn unofficial record
she did revenge porn on official record
it's crazy [__] yeah and so I was
actually driving to do the studio I
shoot my show and I was going to the
studio and while I'm driving the highway
oh [__] I hope Missouri police aren't
watching uh while I'm driving down the
highway I Googled the DC revenge porn
law and what do you know she violated it
now everybody's piling I was like oh
speech debate clause she's investigating
yeah that was that covers her she's
right right then she sent those nude
pics in a freaking email out to her
email list so she said unsolicited nudes
you know yeah stolen um and yeah she
literally sent them out to her email
list as a fundraiser off Hunter's dick
that's really weird it's really weird
even if it's not Fred even if it's not
illegal it's weird for a a congress
person a sitting Congress person to send
revengeborn to their email list and like
give me money because Hunter Biden's got
a huge [__] I I don't understand I I
really don't get it
what what else are they saying what else
are they saying what else are they
saying you should see the mentions of my
Twitter all these [__] people are pie
I literally had a woman today a woman
you know it's probably Russian and her
her her [__] handle alludes to this
stupid movie this you know the the
Trafficking movie that's out with Jim
Caviezel right now you know yeah you're
saving saving the children for being
traffic but she's defending a
congressman sending out someone a
private Citizen's dick pics it's like
you know do you see the [__]
disconnect in your brain wow you're
defending right sending out a privacy's
is Dick Pics while saying oh my kid kids
shouldn't be exposed to porn yeah
they're gonna be explosive form by
watching [__] C-SPAN right now
you know the crazy thing though this is
these are the same people these are the
same people
um that uh hang on just a second people
are saying that let me check your mic uh
can't hear me yeah I well they're saying
maybe turn it up a bit if you can yeah I
don't know I don't know if you're uh
it's not hear me switch over so so here
here's the thing is that these are the
same people these are the exact same
people who
when you when they say we want church
and God back in school you're like well
you know if you have one religion in
schools in public schools the
Constitution you have to have all of
them right you're gonna have all there
you go that's better you gotta have all
of them sorry about that folks you got
to have all of them all of the religions
in school and they're like no no can't
do that these are Christian you know
like then you don't understand what the
document says right like you don't you
don't understand what the document says
so it's the same people so it's not
surprising that they that they would
have a skewed view of of Hunter Biden
and when she's showing porn well again
and for me the the anger came out of the
fact that again it's it's it's it's
right out I kind of think I said I think
I said in Iran I sent a tweet and I said
you know they literally
smeared [__] on the walls of the Capitol
on January 6 2021 and she figuratively
smeared [__] in the capital yesterday I
mean again at some point it we have to
recognize that they've dirtied the the
entire body politic of our country uh
and and no one gives a [__] and this is
Kevin McCarthy's Legacy in my humble
opinion you know kept McCarthy is going
to be go down in history as one of the
most noxious and failed speakers in the
history of the United States of America
he's the speaker of the house I thought
he was just I thought he was held the
office
he's going to have a legacy and his
legacy is he presided over you know
revenge porn being shown in a public
hearing he presided over you know Jim
Jordan who can't seem to find a [__]
jacket you know just the entire clown
show that is the Republican caucus and
that's before we get to the clown show
last week like the ndaa you know where
they loaded up our defense bill with all
the favorite moms for Liberty fantasies
you know let's see we got to band
transgender care affirming care uh we
got to ban books I mean Lauren bobert
made a sneaked bookbag in there I mean
it's pretty [__] impressive to find a
way to ban books in the defense
authorization act but Lauren bow Brazil
pulled off you know they they banned
abortion travel uh they banned Dei you
know all their favorite races bigoted
anti you know homophobe everything they
could load in there uh for our national
spending uh so it's not going to [__]
make through the Senate and right well I
mean I mean it's Dead on Arrival but you
put MTG on the conference committee the
MTG announces she's on the conference
committee oh my God I mean she's not the
punch on that Tony's she's not on the
defense committee she's not on any of
the Committees that relate to the
defense bill
that's why she is the speaker right she
is the speaker of the house because
there's it makes no sense of someone not
on the house committee on defense would
be on the conference committee for the
NCAA except for the fact she's got she's
got Kevin car these balls carefully
placed in a box on her [__] you know
wow
speaking of balls placed properly on
their disk watch watch Debbie Wasserman
Schultz absolutely tear uh RFK Junior
part I think that the best part about
this clip um before I get into it is the
reaction to Jim Jordan that what Jim
Jordan has to do when RFK can't shut his
mouth
when she's spitting facts watch this it
still fuels deadly violence today yet
last week you floated a baseless
conspiracy theory that the coronavirus
was bioengineered to Target Caucasians
and black people but to spare Ashkenazi
Jews and Chinese people Mr Kennedy
you're a bizarre unproven claim Echoes
that same historic slander of labeling
Jews and Chinese people as a race and
that Jews and in this case Chinese
people somehow managed to avoid a deadly
illness that targets other groups for
death you do see that yes or no you're
mistating no no no no you uploaded it I
quoted what you said earlier and it is
directly what you said so just asking I
was describing
and NIH funded no no you didn't cite I
would say I was describing an nih-funded
study by Cleveland clinics
reclaiming my time you did not
reclaiming published in USC medical
which is online the time is mine I'm
reclaing it please ask the witness to
stop talking you asked me a question
reclaiming let me allow me to answer my
question Mr chairman I'd like about 10
seconds
so so the longer the short of it here
and we can get back we'll I'll play the
rest of the clip we got Gabe Sanchez
joining us too he's a little late you
know he's always late here wow wow wow
I was over here I was I just saw the
Barbie movie last night so I was writing
uh another episode of of why Ted Cruz
has [__] Titans oh you know whatever
oh I see I see what good well good well
here's the thing is I think this is the
best part is that Jim Jordan's like oh
[__] I gotta I gotta go against RFK my
witness here because he won't shut his
trap and it only proves that RFK is not
qualified not only to not be on the
presidential stage but not even be a
witness in Congress he can't even figure
out how to be a witness in Congress and
shut his mouth when it when when a
sitting member of Congress is speaking
you don't even know the rules of that
room let alone be a presidential candida
this is ridiculous Am I Wrong Fred or am
I right I don't know maybe he's just a
butt I mean the thing is he he is he is
so deep in his own [__] that when
his own words are read to him he has to
deny it we all saw it he said there's an
argument that it doesn't I mean yeah no
Chinese dot I mean the Ridiculousness of
what he says and and when you get that
far down the rabbit hole lies
conspiracies you're constantly trying to
spin it you know back it up with
something else and you know yeah so he's
just he's desperate but he's not again
going back to the beginning it's a plant
the whole thing is men right to cause
trouble and and that's his job so I I
think but again it goes to what was it
what was one of my guests oh Dennis that
was on my show about two months ago and
he said that Jim Jordan's brand is face
plant you know that that is that is Jim
Jordan I mean he can't resist [__]
face planting every time he does he
thinks he's so clever but he's not he's
not a smart person it's almost like he's
a [__] it's almost like he's a [__] I
mean it always comes back to that scene
from this instance where you know
Sideshow Bob is constantly hitting the
rakes it comes from under the car right
right and they can't help themselves but
I mean like people when they bring up
people like JFK or RFK Jr I'm like yeah
sounds great I would love to see them go
for it right to keep going guys I mean I
even said I was like do not take the
shovel out of this guy's hand we have we
have quotes and and statements and
recordings and tapes of what he said and
the fact that he's trying to now create
this revisionist tale you know very
similar to how Republicans work and it's
like no I have a quote here and I think
that was the clip that you were playing
where she's like no no no yeah right I
have the quote of what you said well I'm
gonna play the rest I'm gonna play the
rest of the clip but the longer the
short of it here I think is is that
people thinking that Joe Biden is even
going to consider debating it's like you
said a plant because he is Maga it's
Maga it's he's not a Democrat yes he may
be a member of the democratic party
maybe a democrat in the past but he's
Maga he is Maga he's supporting Trump
it's trumpism I don't care how you
[__] spin it I don't care what label
you put on it he's uh he's a Maga idiot
he's a Maga [__] now the thing is is
that the way Debbie Wasserman Schultz
hands him his ass here for anyone who
would who would not know this is exactly
why Joe Biden would say why do I need to
debate this person he can't even hold
decorum in as a witness in the House of
Representatives in a Committee hearing
that is designed for him to spread
misinformation he can't even handle
himself there so why would I I'm the
president United States why would I even
debate him this is ridiculous but watch
here what Jim Jordan has to do for
Debbie Wasserman Schultz and it it I
could tell it pains him I can tell it
pains him it's dishonest
myself
I'd like 15 seconds back we will be
happy to give you that thank you so much
you did not cite any study like you are
citing here now during that conversation
you referenced no study at all you
simply labeled Jews and Chinese people
as a race and you also said that somehow
they managed to avoid a deadly illness
that targets other groups for death you
don't see that you're trying to rewrite
history here a few months ago Mr again
we could show the clip again I I think
we already showed it on the show where
what he's saying what he's saying he's
saying it in front of a reporter and
because they said off the record and
then someone recorded and posts online
they're like oh well it didn't exist
because I said off the Record the stupid
trumpian thing or the like because I say
the words off the Record then it
absolutely wipes it from everyone's
memory it's really dumb stuff for it
it's really stupid stuff why why would
anyone take this stuff seriously and why
do we have to go through this exercise
and and then going back to Jim Jordan
right so the thing about Jim Jordan and
this whole exercise is I I keep thinking
they're going to learn at some point but
they don't the the fact is he's playing
he's not playing he's not playing 3D
chess I haven't played 2dj he's playing
checkers you're giving him a lot of
credit by saying they might learn one of
these things I'm a [__] Optimist I
don't know why I'm still this weird guy
that's a hell of a lot of optimism
maybe they're capable of learning but
this [__] guy no that is like
learning thing I know he's just stupid
and they they can't seem to think wow if
you hold a hearing you know the
Democrats might actually [__] fight
back it's literally like going to war
and forgetting there's bad guys like
like you know we're gonna evade Iraq and
look it takes four hours to drive to
Baghdad so let's just plan on that
you know you know I mean sure nothing's
gonna happen we're just gonna drive the
[__] back they're like oh [__]
there's guys with guns it's the same
thing it's like they don't seem to be
able and you could tell he hasn't
coordinated with his a swallow pointed
out there damn I show how during that
Committee hearing with uh that swallow
was on where he was beating him up his
is that they can't even get a cohesive
with the FBI director they came and get
a look when you see the Democrats
they'll go in or a competence committee
they'll have they'll talk to each other
and say all right look you're going to
hit them for this and you're gonna hit
him for this and you're gonna have you
know and then this is the thing the
theme we're looking for is that you know
they they have a a plan a strategy
everybody has their role to play this
[__] guy he just goes let's have a
hearing doesn't have a plan doesn't ever
say Okay so the Democrat argument is
going to be X so let's you're going to
counter that and that's how you do it
it's
you
you're you're telling me you're telling
me that what I've been saying for months
is true is that that when you have
serious people in Congress and they have
serious staff things things actually
turn out in a serious manner because
that's that's the thing I've been
telling the audience people do this for
a living it's crazy and that's that's
the thing is I've been telling the
audience for a long time the reason why
when you watch like Lauren bobert or
Marjorie Taylor green or Matt Getz or
any of these other fools like Jim Jordan
or James Comer they don't have actual
staff that is serious about this stuff
they're not real they're not real staff
because Congress people rely on their
staff and and I want Congress people to
be like these gods that you know they're
super intelligent and they know all but
really honestly it's the reason why
they're so good and the reason why a lot
of these Congress people are so good is
because their staffs are excellent they
have career staff people these are
career staffers that go that go to
college get their degrees go to
Washington to become career staffers on
the hill and they try to look for
serious people because if you don't work
for serious people then you're no longer
a serious staffer that's the thing in
Washington and a lot of people don't
understand that like Debbie Wasserman
Schultz yes did she present that in a
very elegant way and I'm going to show
another clip here ever here because it's
great too I haven't even seen it and I
know it's great
just by the look on her face in the
freeze frame I know it's fantastic but
the point is is that there is a whole
staff of people who have been around
Washington DC they know they know
everything about DC they know Congress
they know the process they know the
procedures and they're all right there
helping Debbie Wasserman Schultz and
like you said they're all working in
coordination to make Congress a serious
place and then you have the contrast of
Jim Jordan who couldn't work his way out
of a series I do want to add something
to what to what Fred said is is the idea
that they come in right I mean like this
is
none of the information that they're
presenting right now is new right
they're not like oh we we got some
testimony or we got some evidence that
no one's seen before all of the
statements that he has said have been
debunked or they've been proven wrong or
they've been presented to say like hey
you actually said this or all of the
studies or or claims that you've made
have been have been proven wrong because
of XYZ
the Republicans had access to that
information
this is like going into a test knowing
there's going to be a test your teacher
telling you look at chapter one three
and five here's the questions here's the
answer to questions and going you know
what
I don't even need to study like I don't
I'm what's that cocaine sex orgies
instead it's like let's do that instead
it's like Republicans are on this
constant senioritis trip they will never
do the work they've labeled I'm gonna
graduate no problem and then sooner or
later the the admission to college has
been rescinded because they didn't do
anything in their senior year but it
really it really is that they go
unprepared knowing that there's going to
be well remember I would argue actually
they are prepared but not for what
they're doing they're not governing
right right yeah they're all preparing
for their Clips on Fox News that's right
right preparing for their OAS you gotta
remember that the reason they won't work
together is because somebody's gonna
have to be the back bencher and that's
what we just describe a system you and I
we all described just now where they
coordinate some people have to do the
grunt work of like just questioning the
witness right or you know I mean it was
saying yeah they're not going to get the
Highlight they're not gonna they're not
gonna get the clip on Twitter and go
viral yeah Jesse Waters Jesse Watson is
going to ask you get you on for saying
so describe what you did that day no you
gotta say you gotta own the list webs so
every single one of those [__] idiots
is trying to own the libs every time
they get a microphone and so they can't
coordinate because they're not actually
working together in any way they're all
working for their own goals and their
own ends which is to own the lips and we
see that we see that in their infighting
with like Lauren bobert and Margaret
David green because she stole she stole
right the whole fight with them is
because she stole the impeaching Biden
Thunder from right it's nothing to do
with policy it's just you're stealing my
[__] Clips
like I really want to impeach Joe Biden
but if she does it then I don't want to
do it right just what the [__] yeah
that's exactly so they are they're just
in cable by actually governing that's
not their goals Governor their goal is
to get a clip on oan the goal is their
own staff you know you know Margie
turken has her Nick Dyer one of the most
idiots biggest [__] idiots in
Washington you know filming everywhere
she walks for a reason she wants to get
her little clip and and get her get her
money and click click click what is that
about why why does she have someone
follow behind her and film her walking
because she said a narcissist but they
always we always want to get the moment
where she's accosted they want to get
the moment I mean when I was at when we
were doing the debate in Georgia for
March March uh for uh Marcus Flowers
Campaign I I I I staffed it and we went
to the studio and she shows up late and
I'm sitting there on my laptop working
on coordinating in the back of the
studio like imagine this giant TV studio
I'm the back in a chair the one chair I
stole it and I'm on my laptop according
our Communications team because we had
social media ready to go you know we
were ready to get Clips you know like a
professional campaign would be she comes
swooping in with her her boyfriend which
we found out later was her boyfriend we
didn't it was weird because Brian Glenn
from right side broadcasting news was
there that's where we found out a week
later it was her boyfriend she was had
an affair with him it's great and then
this Nick Dyer guy who's her little her
little boy and sure enough he's filming
and I go down on my computer I'm tapped
I look up and he's standing over me in
the studio taking a picture of me on his
phone
and I'm like Nick Dyer yeah yeah her
staffer I'm like what the [__] is wrong
with you man yeah this is I think it was
to intimidate me or something like that
what did he did anything what did he
think what did he think he was gonna
accomplish because you were that you
were there right you were there you were
there you knew you were there no you
know they think they can intimidate me
it's like oh go [__] send my picture
I wait I'm like hey
jackass make sure to text make sure to
tag me [__] got your moment it's about
it's about catching her and then of
course the other thing is the excuse she
had for having her boyfriend there
um was that they're doing a reality show
on her that's what that's the big people
forgot that wait wait wait wait wait
back up are you saying they're producing
a reality show on Marjorie that was the
excuse for him sleeping at her house
when she was having an affair with them
but yeah
all right guys I got all the dirt on it
oh man
we're gonna have to have Fred back to do
a whole entity
great great how did the newspapers find
out about her boyfriend it's weird it
could I I wonder woman
right right he's unethical here's here's
the next clip of uh washerman Schultz
and uh again I haven't seen this clip
but I know it's really good just by the
look on her face oh look at that look
look at that look at the look what you
doing here Tony Jesus I just know it
let's watch see that you're trying to
rewrite history here a few months ago Mr
Kennedy you compared coveted Public
Health policies to barbaric murderous
tactics of Nazi Germany saying that
Jewish people in Nazi Germany had more
freedom than Americans facing coveted
Health restrictions in hindsight Mr
Kennedy do you reject this absurd and
deeply hurtful and harmful comparison or
do you still stand by it okay see Fred
you doubted me you doubted me you doubt
it you doubted not not blazing I just
want to point out all right all right
after the audience what do you say oh
we're gonna get to it oh we're gonna get
to see this is what I do on this show
see this is what I do on the show I hold
I hang the audience for just a a little
bit because they're going to say in the
comments the audience
see you see what happened was is you
question my ability to read the
transcript that ason posted on Twitter
so I know what the clip says
I just haven't watched it yet I just
haven't what I just haven't watched it
yet this is this is how I do this is
this this is the Tony Michaels podcast
all right all right let's let's see
because I know the audience wants to see
the the absolute garbage
I I know see you want to see it Tony do
you see do you see how I do do you see
how I gang hang the audience on yeah I
know we got five minutes look I know
time I got time do you got time because
I I got plenty of time and I'm just
kidding okay let's let's see what RFK
Juniors uh pukes up here in the
Congressional hearing Congressman what
you are saying is a lie that you you
said it it's it's I oh I did not I never
can tell you I never ever Mr chairman of
the record when Mr Kennedy said that I
reclaim my time and just see that you're
trying and and I don't know why he keeps
doing this but it almost seems like he
uh is uh um I don't know following the
manga cult and that he says things that
he did I I didn't say that yeah we got
recording of you actually saying those
words it's almost like he thinks Debbie
Wasserman Schultz didn't go back and
look at these clips and get the
transcript and then read them out word
for word verbatim in this Congressional
hearing and then he can lie so what is
what is the penalty for lying in front
of Congress I don't know maybe this is
[Laughter]
this goes to Donald Trump too in in this
and I'm not going to accuse I'm not a
psychologist I spent a lot of time with
psychiatrist or psychologist but I'm not
one but but
he's not well I mean let's be honest the
guy is not mentally well I mean he he he
for he doesn't think he's lying he
firmly believes he didn't say that
because what it's like the thing with
the the the quote that was caught at his
little thing with the the dinner there
well he was citing a study yeah but you
didn't say that you just said there's an
argument like oh yeah but I mean in his
head you know so he doesn't think he's
lying when he says that he thinks he's
telling the truth he's just being cut
off or there wasn't context or you don't
understand and so he doesn't he really
thinks that he may have not precisely
said those words and and so you guys
said in these adult Minds like Trump
well it's just being Twisted against me
you can literally read their words to
them
some people with these mental
deficiencies and they'll say nah it's
that's not what I meant okay but these
are the words you said yeah yeah you
have to understand yeah you cut me off
like no these are the [__] words you
said right and and really you could
argue all day which is what
a lot of people are probably people
probably criticize
um Congressman Washington Schultz
because she keeps cutting them off not
let him talk but because she understands
he'll never say yeah I said that he'll
he'll always say well no you did this
the framework you gotta read the rest of
the quote where I go into great depth on
that quote it's it's like you might as
well argue this this beautiful painting
I overpaid for you could yell at that
all [__] day and robbery Lee is never
going to answer
right it's you know it's just it's it's
talking to RK to get him to actually
believe uh is the same besides Trump
that's why people say oh God confront
Trump he will never hear what he doesn't
want to hear right well I mean it's
constant confirmation bias they hear
what they want to hear they believe that
they're correct they you know just like
you said they they think they said
something in their mind but what came
out was complete gibberish or nonsense
or whatever and it's being quoted back
then they're like oh no no no no don't
don't
yeah you don't understand the context
like but nobody was talking before or
after you said that quote that's that's
the isolated clip in full context you
said it and at the end of the day you're
not a victim so own up to what you said
own up to what you did don't be a little
[__] ass [__]
well the cognitive dissonance I think
you're right drips off of them it the
cognitive dissonance just drips off of
them and I I think to your point where
uh Debbie Wasserman Schultz it's not
about her getting him to admit in an
open hearing that he said what he said
because there's [__] evidence of it
you don't need to for him to say I I
didn't say that when you know he said it
it's to get it on the official record
and I think a lot of people uh a lot of
people don't understand exactly why Jim
Jordan fails so much at the these
Congressional hearings is because he
doesn't really understand like you said
he sees it as an opportunity for him to
get on Fox news but he really doesn't
understand that this is official record
and this record lasts forever it's going
to be there forever and it is going to
judge him this record is going to judge
him through history and really honestly
he will be thrown in the Dustbin of
unserious people and people you
shouldn't even really consider to be
major figures in in the in our political
system them in this time in this crazy
[__] weird wacky ass timeline that we
live in where we're at the intersection
of WrestleMania and real [__] wife I
just it's uh it's crazy stuff and the
cognitive dissonance couldn't be any
more blatantly obvious so and they're
feeding an audience that has the same
business I mean that in the end I
remember this is for this is from in
many ways let's be very honest this is
an audience of one this is for Donald
Trump because the funny thing guys is
we've talked about what half an hour of
an hour we've been talking about this
stupid hearing and how stupid Jim Jordan
is the punch on this whole story is
we've never talked once about why they
thought it was a good idea to call RFK
which is the idea that the government
censored him by losing his Twitter
account that that was the government
right you know the government and that's
the the whole point that that was the
point this hearing you know was to prove
how this poor private citizen whose
Kennedy was was just trying to tell the
truth and the government came and made
him stop tweeting about it and uh and
and that's the stupidity of why Jim
Jordan's not even pay thank 2D chess
he's playing checkers uh with a [__]
monkey in their side and losing I think
it's like I think it's Candyland
Candyland Candyland right
the storyline was ooh Governor
interference so they bring a guy who's a
total [__] crackpot and and that's
what the Dems did so look how brilliant
the Dems have done the entire story of
this hearing is never going to be about
the government weaponizing that yeah no
it's always gonna be about RFK as a
[__] nut job I mean it's like it's
like yesterday they came in to be like
whistleblower X like it was some [__]
superhero gonna come in and save the day
and then the whole hearing is now about
how marjor Taylor green put up nude like
right can somebody search her computer
because the fact that she printed out
nudes of Hunter Biden on poster size
canvas right and she was like oh you
know what I'm gonna one-up myself and
I'm gonna send out a newsletter with
links to video and other Clips so you
guys at your home on you know under your
safety of your own house can watch it on
your own time [__] it pull it up while
you're you know driving or you're in
traffic watch it yourself [__]
lunatics but now the whole thing about
the old IRS whistleblower No No One's
Gonna remember that God it's all about
the fact that she showed revenge porn
did you see did you see during that
hearing how the Democrats did a
brilliant job they didn't actually
attack the witnesses there's like ah
you're a hero you're a professional
maybe you just misheard no no it was and
by the way if you're going back we said
about the strategy like four different
Democrats use the exact same thematic I
think AOC I think uh it doesn't matter
but a couple of them are like oh but
maybe you misunderstood that Raskin the
difference between a special attorney
and a special counselor oh no no I know
what I'm talking about are you sure
because wise himself the guy you're
accusing has said no I wanted to be a
special attorney and so they very they
never bash these guys it was very slick
but again four or five different
Democrats had the exact same thematic
they never there's no video of them
attacking those Witnesses it was it was
brilliant and it's so easy it's so easy
when they bring fake Witnesses though it
really is that easy and smart people are
against them Fred I I want to ask you do
you have just a couple more minutes I
know I know I got you a little over time
do you have a couple yeah why not here's
the reason why because it's lunch time
we're talking we're talking about
Marjorie Taylor green showing the porn
yesterday and Tennessee Brando made a
great song about it and I want to play
later and see what your response is
let's see let's see what Tennessee
Brando came up with oh marjorie's got a
hard-on for Hunter
[Music]
talks about him all the time
they drive her out of her mind
[Music]
she drives like hell to suppress it
she tries
[Music]
at least that's what we suspect
Junior's got a heart on for Hunter
he always hands me on the plane
for all of his dirty feelings
[Music]
he thinks that we all can't see
the little twinkle he gets in his eyes
don't think we have to ask why
with all the world's problems getting
back on our feet
breaking our backs just to make ends
meet they just can't help it they just
can't stop
demanding the sea honors laptop
they all got a heart on for Hunter
who's there to fight and distract
truth won't get in the way of their
stores
they won't be
[Music]
dirty
but he did back in his days
but they all got a hard-on for Hunter
and the truth is they just couldn't hang
they're nice very nice uh I couldn't I
couldn't say it better myself what a way
to finish the the Fred Wellman what do
you think of that music video
I mean the whole the whole thing about
her being the legal Christian my
favorite thing on Earth was Marty Taylor
green when she posted the picture of her
underneath all the crosses on her wall
reading her Bible and I knew at that
point she was sleeping with a guy for
the right side broadcasting news network
while she went to all the mega rallies
uh it's just it's just the not just
Insanity man I mean I mean for a group
for a group that [__] loves to say
Democrats are are yeah indoctrinating
yeah America with
um with gay propaganda or whatever it's
like they shove a lot of [__] in our
face okay
you got it out there baby they got I got
a lot of them that's right girls on all
the hot dogs
that's literally the Republican party
right now
give us a Shameless plug here Fred
Wellman before we go oh yeah FP Wellman
on the Midas touch Network we Premiere
new shows every Friday night at 11. uh
it's also my channel on YouTube on
Democracy podcast on YouTube of course
I'm on FP Wellman on on Twitter and FB
woman official on uh Instagram and
threads uh got a great show I actually
interviewed this week a woman named
Crystal Quaid
um she is the Democratic candidate for
governor here in Missouri then the House
minority leader in a super majority
state so it's an interesting
conversation talking about why a red
State matters how how the laboratory of
autocracies
works here in Missouri where I live uh
so I think it's an interesting
conversation for people nationally I
understand just the crazy [__] that
happens here how they successfully
battle it as a minority but uh that's
gonna be a good show I'm excited of
course last week I had Eric swallow well
he's dropping f-bombs it's great
we do we all we do all the hard-hitting
content here yes on the Tony Michaels
podcast when we play Tennessee Brando
singing hard on for Hunter yeah hard
ones for hunters quality content man
that's it this is politics this is
politics in 2023 Fred woman thanks for
joining us my friend come back soon
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6. and
if you're one of the other members of
Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Gabe Sanchez was shaking his finger at
me
angry there for a second I was trying to
get the link for the Tennessee Brando
video everyone's wanting the link
[Music]
a video
you gotta follow Tennessee Brando if you
want those music videos he does these
songs he pops them off like that every
once in a while and when it's like that
I'm trying to uh to find oh look at this
I'm all jacked up here there we go
jacked up jacked up what jacked up uh
we're suppose that major oh Jetta I
don't know if we'll be able to connect
we'll see
um able to come on is when I'm gonna
message him that way um so I'm hoping we
can get major ojetta here on Fred's
always a Greek is oh he always agree
he's great he's got a large wealth of
knowledge go ahead what I was gonna say
I have an update on uh so I did what was
that for for anyone who hasn't seen it
or did watch on the show I did what was
that on Mike Lindell yeah and Mike
Lindell yeah at an auction oh really
turns out that auction was a [__]
flop
come on it's Mike Lindell you're telling
me that I mean blocked come on some of
the site I believe you 100 the equipment
some of the account for like 10 bucks
like dollars of worth of equipment
because it's just an online bidding site
so now wait a second he was having this
auction because he's going broke right
or is it just because he has to shut
down his business because no one will
buy his [__] no no what happened was
he said uh well he's like the left is
canceling me they did a cancel culture
on me a hundred million dollars of you
know they're suppressing or canceling up
you know that [__]
what ended up happening was Mike Lindell
decided to invest 40 million dollars if
not more into this whole conspiracy that
there was voter fraud from the from the
Democrats trying to suppress votes you
know the Chinese machines and I'm gonna
have a lawsuit against all the machines
in the world and all this [__]
so he had to have this auction because
big box retailers that formerly had him
were like no we're not going to work
with the [__] lunatic we're not doing
that so they canceled their contract and
he had to shift his business model to
pretty much all online sales there are a
couple like Menards I think still has
them which is a random place that you
would find pillows I guess but uh but
hey Menards sells milk and groceries
Yeah well yeah well I don't actually I
haven't been to a Menards since I lived
in Chicago so at that time they sell it
was like groceries you'd always go up
and it was like here's this like kids
playhouse outside and then you go in
yeah they always have like off-brand
stuff too like instead of a MAG light
it's like a schmag light you know what I
mean yeah yeah like like oh yeah you
know the name brand is Maglite right oh
schmag lights
you know to each their own but what what
happened was he put in 40 million he
said he was
canceled for a hundred million so like
maybe 140 million total if not more and
cancel what you mean like cancel
contracts where they were going to buy
yeah yeah he was like they did it well
the quote was they did a canceled
culture on it was they did a cancel
culture on us and he said that a hundred
million dollars was lost because they
they killed their contracts but again we
live in a in a market where you can
decide if you want to continue working
with someone or not so that's completely
up to you as a private business and they
just said they said hey look man you're
crazy and the [__] you say is not good
for our brand so we don't want any of
that
so this guy's out you know potentially
140 plus million dollars and he has to
have a an auction on kbid.com for my
pillow equipment from like uh uh
what packaging material uh he was
selling iMacs tablets
um there were other manufacturing
forklifts he was selling trucks I mean
this [__]
I mean it's it's clear that this guy is
going under and he was having this
auction and then it just turns out that
he wasn't able to make any money on this
auction to recruit that's great he
actually lost money because this is
worth money more than one yeah because
remember and then he had to pay the
auction company the auction and foreign
because we had a Home Depot in a Menards
where I lived and uh we would go to
Menards from time to time and they had a
slide that was like a display slide it
was like a curved yellow slide from like
the top floor down right because they
have a mezzanine and a Muslim yeah yeah
but it was just for display only and I
remember as a kid
hooking over the railing oh she's
sliding down but then not being able to
get out of the slide because the end of
the tube so people wouldn't jump into it
was cover right so by the time then
you're stuck in the slide open you're
like nine feet above the ground and so I
I definitely had done that like maybe
once or twice ah okay yeah you
definitely had done that well speaking
of crazy crazy lunatics uh manga
lunatics have you seen this uh uh this
movie sound what does it sound sound of
sound of idiots is that what it is sound
of idiots so I can't know that do you
know that the [__] that this guy is okay
hold on I just wanna the sound of
Freedom this anti-human Trafficking
movie with [__] Jim Caviezel the
[__] wannabe Jesus [__] all right
this guy
is is playing in the the sad thing about
this is this actually might get like a
nomination okay because it's got
decently right larger names and some of
these people
from what I understand some of these
people did not know the whole Q Anon
backstory right right in addition to
that the stuff that Jim caviezel's
character is is playing right turns out
that this guy didn't actually do what
they're claiming that he did he took
credit for saving children that he
didn't actually save there's a bunch of
stories like oh this and this and that
and these these kids were recovered and
they were saved and this and that he
took credit for it he's not the actual
guy that did it so this story is All
more like he did some stuff but there's
a ton of other stories that they're
building behind this guy to say oh he
saved all these children he's a [__]
godsend this guy's a savior turns out he
didn't do any of it
well here he is on Fox and Friends this
morning listen to how he describes
himself and how he describes Trump
um in this little clip here it's
yeah this is this is crazy [__] listen
we have to do a lot more and we got to
start with Donald Trump
what do you mean well he's got to be in
there because he's going to go after the
traffickers do you think do you think he
understands that we were with him last
night oh I didn't know that story yes
he's going to be moved to do this do
something I didn't know that last night
this is the new Moses I mean I'm still
Jesus but he's the new Moses
did he I think he just said that he's
Jesus and and this is these are the
people that they're like oh Christian
they're Christian and they're claiming
now you don't know he played Jesus yeah
and do you know do you know how he
prepared for that role for Jesus uh-huh
go ahead so he only he learned Latin
like like Roman Latin right uh and uh he
there was every day I think it was every
day on set he worked with a priest
and then would study his lines like the
dude [__] believes that he's Jesus
okay by the end of filming they were
like this is there's method and then
there's like what the [__] is this so so
let's explain method acting to the folks
here in the audience yeah go ahead so
method acting is just you are you know
you get cast in a role and for this
example let's say it's Jesus or it could
be anyone who does like a biopical or
any rule really right you have a
character you have a backstory
especially if it's based on a real
person like like Jim care and certain
actors are method actor like Jim
Carrey's a method actor Robert De Niro
is a famous method actor there's several
actors in Hollywood that they use this
as their way to yeah you know the the
actor who played
um
uh
I'm like on his name right now but he
was in succession uh that actor who
played
I'm playing on his name anyway he's a
method actor and actually somebody like
like it's good performance but not great
for you as a as a person because what
happens is you have to learn to
disassociate yourself from the role and
Jim Caviezel here right and other people
um
[Music]
right like the reason that he's like
decided to go into fashion is because
the last movie he did he was a fashion
designer and so like you really embodied
these roles and you learned to be that
character Jim Carrey did it on man on
the moon right and so he would be on set
and he would be Andy well he'd be
playing Andy Kaufman and his his other
character that he was and it was so hard
it was so hard for them to do the
production sometimes because Jim wasn't
Jim he was [__] Andy and he would be
playing him all the time like from the
time he woke up our learning or not
learning but the people who are method
actors sometimes you get like Great
Performances and sometimes you're like
this is [__] bananas because it
worked out when it is bananas right
right and but they believe that they are
that person they believe that when you
know Jim Caviezel is this guy who is
this like anti-human trafficker he like
saves all these kids and all this stuff
he truly will believe and does believe
that he is that person that he does save
those people that he did do all those
amazing things even though it's all
built on lies you know I think he's
Jesus too why not I mean you know we
might I mean if you want to believe that
you're
uh Jesus that's totally fine you know
like if yeah
there we go somebody Jeremy Strong from
succession which by the way great show
definitely watch it it's pretty much
more or less Loosely based on the
Murdoch's a little trumpism in there
um it's a great show but Jeremy Strong
is another one who is a uh
caretakers also saying Leonardo DiCaprio
I didn't know that I didn't I didn't
know Leo was a method actor yeah I
couldn't believe that though is he I
know Robert I know Robert De Niro is a
famous method actor
um he he kind of but but Robert De Niro
is more coupled to reality so it's
easier for him to un undo the method I
guess so I guess in for his role in the
Revenant Leonardo DiCaprio pushed things
to the next level but this is only one
example so I don't know if he does it
more than this but the actor not only
camped out in the wilderness to prepare
but he also slept in an animal carcass
ate raw bison and swam in frozen rivers
on a daily basis does that sound like
him
I don't know I think that's a lie I
don't I don't believe it the Hollywood
icon isn't known as no he's not oh no
this seems to be so this was a one roll
it looks like from what I'm reading now
Leonardo but it is not a method actor
it's just a technique it is a technique
in acting right it's a technique that
you use in acting um and and a lot of a
lot of actors famously use that
technique for every role that they get
it's one reason why a lot of these
methan actors only do so many movies and
the reason why is because it takes them
that long to get the character and then
get the [__] out of the character yeah
like they can't do six movies a year
because they're not they are not able to
do it with that technology it's in the
same in a similar note it's why people
were you know the um
the actor who played Elvis right
everyone's like oh man you know you've
got uh Austin Butler people are like oh
he can't get rid of the accent the
accent is him now like he's he's
embodied this right he's done every year
it's him and he's gonna he's gonna take
him a while to get out of that because
if you compare before and after have you
ever seen this though have you ever seen
this like uh you know someone well
you're you're from Chicago and Chicago
has a certain accent yeah yeah and you
move away and you kind of get you know
you get away from that accident and then
you go back and it doesn't take but
maybe a week and you're saying I've got
friends who are from Texas and they go
back and they come back and then they
they like get the twang again and get
that long yeah
but they'll go back visit family come
back to LA and then they've got a little
bit like a twink for a little bit and
then they go back into their right
they're like their new uh occurrence so
yeah well there's also there's also a
thing in sales method that is called
mirroring and you mirror someone's
speech pattern you mirror their volume
you mirror their accent um you mirror
how they're talking
um because it makes them feel more
comfortable and the reason why is
because they they don't you don't sound
weird to them and well people yeah
people like hearing themselves well
right to an extent they like hearing
themselves talk and you know I mean I
certainly do yeah you know clearly
but like when I clearly that's the thing
that I like uh as a designer when I do
user testing and I'll like go to a cafe
or something and I'll be like hey can I
get your quick feedback I just need five
minutes your time and just run through a
quick exercise and you're like okay well
I don't have much time and you're like
great and then you end up talking for
like 20 minutes because people want to
be heard and they want their opinion to
be listened to by another person so they
are more than willing
on YouTube says Don Jr is a meth actor
that's right probably pretty close I
think I think I bet Don Jr's done
something OD actor yeah that's dude
that's true well so um I don't mean to
get on sales tactics too much but the
thing is is that uh sales people do have
tactics and Trump uses almost every
single one of them projection is one of
the biggest one that he used but also
um it makes them look bone-headed
sometimes and you pointed out this
morning because I want to play one more
clip of this hearing with uh um Jr
excuse me RFK Jr JFK Jr has a pineapple
I slipped up earlier I was like oh yeah
he and he hadn't come back to life yet
we have RFK Jr here no he's still alive
it's all a conspiracy right it's if
there's one person that's gonna believe
that RFK uh or JFK JFK Jr like all of
them are still alive it's gonna be RFK
Jr I feel like he's oh absolutely he's
like yeah
yeah man so uh RFK Jr here is uh gonna
testify before Congress now this is
rewinding all the way back to the
beginning of the hearing where Jim
Jordan seems to fail to do something
that is very important for a chairman to
do in a hearing like this when you have
witnesses but watch Daniel Goldman
easily dunk him and it's not and Daniel
Goldman is not even like intentionally
dunk him in the trash he's just like hey
dude did you forget to do something
watch this I will now go with opening
testimony Mr Kennedy you are recognized
for your opening statement
thank you
as a line as mine's not make sure it's
Mr chairman are you going to swear in
the witnesses
you're gonna you're gonna lift the lid
before you piss in it please uh stand
and raise your right hand
oh Jordan you are such a loser I like
how I like how RFK Jr was like oh what
why can't I speak and it's like because
we haven't officially started the
[__] right because we haven't turned
the microphones off yet because
this is the government they're trying to
suppress my voice just swear in dude
right you said that that's all it is man
you said Jim Jordan class idiot what a
[__] [__] I mean you have one job
one if you're gonna if you're gonna
throw a [__] sham hearing okay do
your job and at least start the normal
proceeding as it should be like right
out of the gate you [__] up like the
gates open and you tripped and you fell
and everyone else is ahead of you in the
race so when you when you watch these
hearings and the cameras on the Congress
people right that are sitting asking
questions they normally have staffers
behind them those are those people
behind them that's their staff that that
are behind them and you'll sometimes
they'll get up and they'll like hand
them a piece of paper or their whisper
something in their ear or their they'll
hand them something or they'll say
something to them or maybe they'll text
them on their phone and there should
have been a staffer there tapping Jordan
on the shoulder like no no no no you
gotta you gotta swear them in even the
staffers are so funny I mean that's
assuming but again this goes back to
this whole like Lauren bobert Margaret
Taylor green you have to assume right
that the staffers are competent enough
to know those things Lauren bobert
you've pointed out several times she
doesn't know actually how to uh you know
back her time I yield
to what what are you yielding stop signs
I don't know what are we doing you can
yield to anyone I yield to the guy who's
watching the door in the back I yield to
the person who's behind crazy RFK Jr
it's it's a a [__] circus man you got
clowns running you got you got really
what you got is you got [__] the
inmates running the Asylum here you've
got people you got the [__] uh psych
ward inmates running the Asylum that's
in uh you know one flow of the Cuckoo's
Nest
I want to show you since we showed the
Tennessee Brando video I gotta show you
the Fox news clip and Marjorie Taylor
green
um really really wanting to get Hunter
Biden's [__] all the way out I mean you
know I I have to assume that
the
the sexual relationship that she has
with Brian Glenn is not satisfying
because she has to look at
Hunter Biden's [__] at any point she's
like oh yeah I gotta do some I gotta do
some uh uh research and preparation for
the meeting tomorrow honey okay goes
down to the kitchen loads up that
[__] HP PC and she's like ah Hunter
Biden's dick and then she's like search
filter blur off yeah let me see that
[__] that's what she's doing she's like
you know illuminated face in the dark of
her kitchen she's opening the laptop to
look at another man's penis because
clearly the guy that she was it's
evidently gave its evidence it's evident
if it's evidence and if you knew that
Hunter biting his dick was big before
holy [__] boom she prints it out huge
yeah huge huge okay
let's watch this Marjorie Taylor green
uh presents the American people of what
she loves the most which is Hunter
Biden's hog into a foreign-based amateur
online pornography platform
um this this is evidence
of Hunter Biden making sex tape this
guy's like what the [__] going on
coming making pornography should we be
displaying this Mr chairman to a foreign
this I mean the The Whistleblower X Mr
Ziegler here that they thought was going
to be this like [__] Smoking Gun is
super confused I that might be his like
representation like legal representation
next to him that guy's like whoa what
are we doing here what's going on like
everyone is right well and that's the
reason why they're confused is because
they don't know why the Republicans are
doing this and the reason why
Republicans are doing this is exactly
what Fred Wellman said they're doing
this to get on the the television the
trader TV news networks that's what
they're doing now Fred pointed out that
there's a revenge porn law in DC I guess
um but her showing anything in evidence
on to Congress is absolutely outside
that law and the reason why is because
there is a speech in debate clause and
they do Congress people do have the
right to submit stuff into evidence that
otherwise might be um outside of local
municipalities and local laws and the
reason why is because it may be evidence
that's why she specifically says this is
evidence it only tells me she knows what
she's doing she knows what she's doing
when she said this is evidence meaning
I'm I'm I like this I like this porn but
it's evidence right like that's what
she's doing and but Fred did point out
when they uh when she sent it out in her
email to get donations that that's
possibly a violation of yeah of revenge
porn I don't know I I mean you know I
think I think it's also yeah it's it's
hard to it'll be hard to to debate that
I mean like I'm sure whether or not and
it's gonna be on the charger it's gonna
be already the other thing too that I'll
tell you is that the thing that it is uh
and and a lot of people said oh people
should sue her Hunter should sue her for
defamation I'm like he can't sue her for
defamation in a for Testimony or for her
questioning in a congressional hearing
yeah especially if she's doing in a
certain way where she's saying it's
evidence when it's not really evidence
but she's presenting it as evidence and
I'd hate to tell you that I hate to
burst your bubble but they're just not a
goddamn thing they can do about that
right the email thing the email thing
where they're raising money off pictures
that they stole from him that's probably
defamation yeah I would say that's
probably defamation and I would say
there's probably going to be a lawsuit
or at least a seasoned assistant to
Marjorie Taylor Green in her campaign
and they're probably gonna have to
return the money that they received uh
any fundraising they receive from this
email yeah yeah it's I mean it's
um really crazy that we have a congress
where where they're only because really
I mean let's call what it is the reason
that she showed those photos is a
distraction from Donald Trump's current
you know pending third indictment right
and they do not want Democrats to have
the narrative
that they can
they can move forward with they do not
want to lose the ability
to have something on the bidens
When Donald Trump is looking at a third
fourth fifth indictment in the coming
uh weeks and months
so this is all they have right again
this goes back to gal Luft
the guy is not an actual witness and
he's not a whistleblower he's a spy
Republicans know this they knew this but
they did not think that it was going to
be revealed in the way that it was and
it wasn't going to burst their [__]
bubble they thought that bringing in you
know Mr Ziegler this Democrat gay notice
you know he's got a colorful tie on you
know the Republicans he's Democrat he's
gay he could not possibly be a plant he
could not possibly be someone that's
working with his group even though we
have testimony of things of the WhatsApp
messages like well we never saw we just
kind of summarize what other people said
and then you've got this moment where
they're like oh you know what we are
prepared to [__] Trojan Horse this
dick picking
and show it because we're talking about
Hunter Biden IRS Hunter Biden laptop we
gotta find a way to bring it in look at
these dicks and it's like what improving
right right I mean what does that have
to do with any Chinese payment rather he
took not at all
if we really
Margie Taylor green we can talk about
how your Affairs you know and your
insider trading by having coveted you
know uh knowledge we could I can connect
all those dots I can say the fact that
you never disclose your relationship
with Brian Glenn you know to his
audience before you started getting
interviewed like that might be a little
bit of a an Ethics violation there like
there's all these things that you could
come back to these people who are
projecting other people's lives right
the fact that I mean like she would have
I I guarantee if she could have she
would have played video that they had
found on a laptop or a phone to be like
look at Hunter Biden and again
there's plenty of them apparently yeah
yeah and you look at you look at Ziegler
the guy that's supposed to do The
Whistleblower and you look at the guy
that's to the right of him which again
I'm assuming is his legal counsel
representation it is his counsel there
and right and both of them are looking
like
like what like we're here to we're here
to I'm here to talk about Hunter Biden
IRS stuff and payments you guys are
showing dick pics I'm very confused
my my counsel is very confused like you
look at their faces and they're like
like you're like what is going on here
like this is this is what happens you
get a whistleblower you get someone to
testify to to help the Republicans and
then sure enough the Republicans are
going to throw a complete mess of this
and even the even the the Witnesses are
like wait what did I just sign up for I
thought we were here to talk about this
thing why why are we why are we talking
about this well I mean but this is
Republicans they can't help but focus on
genitalia everything is about genitalia
to them I mean no matter what it is no
matter where they go they can't even in
bathrooms they can't help but focusing
on someone else's genitalia I want to
tell you we gotta we gotta be honest I
think we've got uh new folks here and
I'm trying to see if I can get a major
Jetta on but our schedules are
conflicting here right I know he was he
was running back from somewhere so I'm
not sure exactly if he'll make it to be
on time for the show if he doesn't
um we certainly we certainly will be we
certainly we certainly will be having
him on next week
um now I want to show you this clip here
for this is from the whistleblowers
yesterday but this lays out uh
representative Garcia really lays out
why they're doing and saying what
they're saying and what it's distracting
from possibly let's listen and I want to
point out that no Biden family members
hold government positions of any kind
now this is of course in stark contrast
to the Trump crime family
the majority conveniently glazes over
the Trump's family's foreign dealings
the Trump family will of course were
actually appointed to White House senior
jobs from ivanka's Chinese trademarks to
Jared's Qatari real estate bailout and 2
billion in Saudi private Equity money so
where's that investigation they were
actually in the white house and I and I
want to point out that no Biden family
members and there you go that's a
distraction because they're really upset
that Hunter Biden is Joe Biden's son and
he's I know done deals overseas with his
business but they failed to mention they
failed to mention the actual Trump
children and the Trump family members
that were in the White House held
official government positions going
overseas in their official official
capacity in the government and making
personal business deals while they were
on government business Jared Kushner
Ivanka Trump you [__] scumbags listen
this is all distraction it's all
projection you can guarant goddamn tea
it if they got a [__] honor I'm
pastor name that they're all it is is
lies and misinformation because that's
the only thing they got left they can't
do anything else but that
they they just don't
have I don't know if they're capable at
all of holding legitimate hearings
bringing real Witnesses or even asking
those Witnesses even if they are
legitimate asking them actual questions
that would help further their narrative
because again like I was telling you and
Fred is like
they know the questions they to the exam
you know with uh
specifically with RFK Jr they know
everything that he said and they know
everything that's been said against him
in terms of debunking his claims and
Republicans still say yay bring them on
up you know like [__] Price is Right
come on down and he's up there and he's
like all right here's my thing and he
says it
and then everyone's like actually we
have a video we have quote or we have
statement or whatever it is it's it is
you saying this thing that's the
complete opposite of what you're saying
right now he's like no no I'm a victim
but that's all they have all these
Witnesses when challenged and it doesn't
take it doesn't it's not rocket science
it doesn't take a [__] genius to
challenge these people
because the people they tend to bring up
are idiots right we the Twitter files
what come on now all this up you got
Twitter you got RFK Jr you've got
Ziegler here to be this whistleblower X
again it every one of these Witnesses if
they do whistleblower X because they
thought that it would like invoke X-Men
movies or something or I honestly think
they said whistleblower X because it
sounded exciting whistleblower X I would
have been much more it's like it's like
Mr costume on well it's like Mr X from
The Simpsons right and it turned out it
was just Homer with a like a little
he's got like a sack with a question
mark over his face and so that's all
that these are to Republicans they think
well rather they don't think yeah that
it's going to be checked they don't
think that it's ever going to be
verified speaking of that remember we
were playing the clip of washerman
Schultz saying that RFK Jr was talking
about Nazis remember that clip where
Fred kind of gave me [__] he's like oh
you yeah great production you haven't
even seen this video I bred the
transcript come on come on man but here
is here is RFK Jr and this I think
Patriot takes his post this this I think
he says the exact opposite of what
Debbie Wasserman Schultz says I almost
actually I I bet it's it's exactly what
she said they're gonna have the right to
compel
unwanted medical interventions on us we
you know the Nazis did that in the camps
in World War II they tested vaccines on
Gypsies and Jews
and the world was so horrified after the
war
and we signed the Nuremberg Charter
and we all pledge when we do that
we would never again impose unwanted
medical interventions on human beings
without informed consent
okay okay again I can't take much more
of this you did have informed consent no
one held anyone down no one held anyone
down and forced them to take a vaccine
that is all [__] that is all
[__] RFK knows this because he
[__] required people to get their
vaccine to come to a [__] party
um this is ridiculous if anyone forced
anyone RFK it might have been you so
what does that say about you
[__] this is so ridiculous and
it's obvious that washerman Schultz was
telling the truth because RFK did say
this in some stupid weird ass interview
whatever the [__] this is of course he
said this oh and Big Stuff Stan says uh
I wasn't I I didn't practice my my RFK
Juniors was okay so what what RFK Jr has
uh people like oh did he have a stroke
or something no he has spasmodic
dysphonia so that's why you hear his
voice the way it is it's that's just
what it is it's a it's a chronic
neurological voice disorder
um and it causes that type of yeah it's
hard to listen to yeah no it is I mean
it's again this is one of those things
that the Republicans would attack Joe
Biden over oh this guy's stutter and
he's so incompetent oh man he's got uh
he's he's got uh right he's impaired or
some [__] he can't even speak and then
and then you you look at Republicans and
how they hoist up RFK Jr as the Savior
meanwhile you can get probably 75
percent of what he's saying
when he's talking and well you know this
is the same thing like this is the same
thing this same thing when they're like
look RFK Junior's so jacked he can bench
press 100 pounds three times he's he oh
man he's a gym bro and they're like we
gotta listen to him on health Anthony
fauci runs like eight miles of [__]
day and he's like in his 80s
[__] and you're like we can't
listen to fauci okay well you can't you
can't have one and not the other way you
[__] you can't see Joe Biden is
a dementia red and Grandpa and he can't
even work his way out of a wet paper
sack and he shuffles his feet around
stage and then you watch him on a
[__] bicycle riding a bicycle come on
man
you're saying two things at the same
time and you also you also can't come
after people who get the jab right oh
don't stick that needle in my arm that
dude's [__] taking steroids Also
let's talk about the RFK Jr used to do
heroin so if we're gonna attack people
over get in the gym
what presidential candidate hasn't done
heroin you know just a little h no big
deal but when Republicans want to come
after drugs and this and look at San
Francisco and look at Philadelphia and
look at this place and look at Portland
whatever it might be
they are you mean people like Matt gants
and Don Jr yeah they're just constantly
attacking themselves because the people
they are attacking
are also people who are you know
past victims or current users or
whatever it might be
so that when they bring up RFK Jr like
this guy's legitimate and you're like on
what in what way what merits does RFK Jr
have other than having the last name
Kennedy because he wouldn't be anyone
let I mean let's be honest here guys RFK
Jr would not be in the position he is
right now he would not have the voice he
has right now or the influence if he
didn't have the last name Kennedy and
every single one of his family members
are like this guy's a [__] whack job
right he shouldn't be not trust this guy
this guy should not be running he is
giving our last name a bad reputation
not only not only should he not be
running he should be in front of a
microphone like this guy should not be
speaking in front of a microphone this
is ridiculous this is this it's just
nonsense it's dumb because any time they
make a claim immediately it can be
pushed back against them and proven
wrong and debunked and it happened
throughout that whole testimony and
that's I was like this is amazing they
really wanted to bring RFK Jr thinking
this is going to be the thing that
[__] blew it all up to expose the
government yeah a weaponization and just
like Fred said right the whole idea was
that he had an account suppressed on on
Twitter and it was the government and no
one in the government we're not even
talking about that and now we're not
even talking about that and on top of
that if we're going to talk about the
government using their influence and
control we'll go all the way back to
[__] ass [__] Donald Trump telling
Twitter hey you should go after Chrissy
Teigen because she's a big meanie yeah
Republicans don't like me remember that
part she called me a [__] to cancel her
account she called me a [__] that's
mean
so I mean like look you could you could
try all you want but it's not going to
work here's the AOC clip Fred was
talking about earlier where you know
you're dropping facts and using I don't
know
strategic
strategy just using strategy to
basically dunk these Republican in the
trash in their narrative in the trash
here's AOC yesterday in this hearing and
again they're all one and the same this
stupid [__] whistleblower hearing is
the same as this stupid hearing today on
RFK it's just a bunch of Republican
nonsense but let's watch this clip from
AOC here
in addition to that if we want to talk
about charges that have been dismissed
and if we do want to follow the evidence
perhaps we should discuss Ivanka Trump's
investigation being charged who was
close to being charged with felony fraud
after Donald Trump's personal attorney
provided political contributions to the
local D.A those charges were dismissed
and ultimately we saw that that that
that D.A Vance
president Trump's attorney provided over
50 000 in political contributions after
the case was dismissed
so we talk about political contributions
I would hope if we are following the
evidence that that we are willing that
this committee if this committee is
going to go there that they'd be willing
to open investigations into the
dismissal of charges against Ivanka
Trump boom I I got to tell the audience
Our Guest is is here major Richard Ojeda
maybe we get him to respond here uh to
this clip from AOC major at welcome how
are you buddy I'm sorry man I took a dad
going to run my GPS wasn't working
properly the next thing I'm on the back
roads on the way here man well good well
you know what we got we got 10 minutes
we got 10 minutes here so give us your
give us your Lowdown of what the uh the
[__] show in Congress is uh this was the
AO this was the the uh hearing yesterday
on the fake whistleblowers
AOC is always on fire but you know you
could literally tell with the
questioning of these whistleblowers and
you could tell how they are absolutely
Trump balloons you know I mean they're
there to make sure that they say
everything that is you know Trump's
great everybody else is bad Hunter
Biden's horrible you know it's it's it's
absolutely sickening about this and once
again you know AOC hits it on the nail
where you know here you guys are
screaming investigation investigation
but you don't want to investigate
anything else that comes on your side
you know you know every you know on
January 6 Kevin McCarthy was livid about
what Donald Trump had done and now he's
a chicken [__] coward like he always is
and now it's they're going after him
because he's leading in the polls you
know they're willing to give him a you
know a pass but once again these are the
same people that drug President Obama
through the garden because he played
golf and didn't say nothing when Donald
Trump outplayed President Obama more in
his term than Obama did in two terms
because they're all double standard [__]
bags is what they are and uh other I
mean to me when I think about leaders uh
it amazes me how shitty civilian leaders
are you know and let me tell you that's
how it is on on all levels County
Commission Boards of Education there's a
lot of people in this country that claim
to be leaders and I'm telling you what
they couldn't lead their thumb up their
ass and it's an absolute fact and uh it
just amazes me amazes me these people
are Crooks and they get away with it and
it's just it's it's a it's like a
never-ending story
you know I I have to say I found a
picture of Marjorie Taylor green and I I
don't know if this is real or not but
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna say it's real
why not
the audience knows me she was holding up
porn yesterday uh she she's obsessed
with Hunter Biden's heart on as
Tennessee Brando's song uh says but
apparently she was holding up some other
porn I don't know if this is a real or
not I have no idea that's what they
should have been holding up
and once again you know Hunter Biden is
a private citizen to me immediately the
moment that Mark to train wreck green
held that photograph up of him nude I
hope that he contacted his logger
because I don't care who you are and
he's a private citizen they can say all
the crap they want but she needs to be
sued she needs her to have her ass sued
off for that garbage well and and we
were talking about this with Fred
Willman earlier and it seems like the
speech and abatecons would protect her
in the correctional hearing but she was
sending fundraising emails with the same
pictures
um so I don't think that's going to give
her any sort of immunity in the speech
and Abate Clause when you're when you're
raising money off of the hunter Biden's
news that are stolen from his laptop and
we know it's stolen and the reason why
is because Leb Barnes has said that
before Le partnes has said no Rudy
Giuliani they stole his laptop and
copied the hard drive and of course we
know now through the forensics with the
investigation in Delaware that that
laptop can is not his the laptop they
keep saying is his laptop you know the
one that Matt Getz tried to everyone
be on a thumb drive ready to go it's not
the laptop that is not the laptop that
is the Republican version of the laptop
because for whatever reason they really
think that this this Narrative of Hunter
Biden is going to take down Joe Biden
for some reason and I don't I don't
understand it because no one gives a
[__] do you give a [__] about Hunter
Biden major do you give a [__] about him
I don't give two shits about Hunter by
you know what but somebody mentioned
this also what about the investigation
into Ivanka Trump and how the the Trump
children absolutely enrich themselves
you know what about Jared Kushner you
know and I'm going to tell you man you
know with Jared Kushner I'm starting to
think that you know there's a big
possibility that he played a big role in
the uh Jamal khashoggi you know
situation where you know he probably
helped the Saudis know exactly when and
where to do it uh I mean you know you
can't trust these people they're they're
garbage and once again it's
you know I sit here all the time and I
and I listen to these these Trump
balloons you know uh there was a person
that was asking these people at Trump
rallies should Hunter by should Hunter
Biden be impeached and it took all the
way until about 150 people before
somebody says 100 miles is not the
president
teach him impeach him I mean these
people are blood just mind-numbingly
stupid and it's like you know they they
just don't they don't pay no attention
they don't research anything and then
you had Jordan klepper who was the
brilliant guy when he does this stuff
and he sits with this one woman and she
says she says you know Biden does this
he says nope that's not that's been
proven false okay well uh Biden to this
nope that's been proven false does it
count uh but now Trump did this and she
just goes I don't care
that's the thing it comes down to I
don't care no matter what you tell me no
matter what you show me no matter how
many facts you've got I don't care
because Donald Trump hates the same
color people that we hate and that's it
and I'll tell you another thing too I
don't know if you saw this but there's
another uh uh ad out right now that is
basically Donald Trump saying you know
they're doing they're doing horrible
things to us and we're going to do even
much more horrible things back oh I've
got that video I've got that video yeah
yeah this guy is literally and that's
what kills me and I'll take another
thing too uh I forget who said it
no Jamie Raskin said it you know if
Donald Trump gets to be able to push off
his court date until the presidential
election every freaking murderer in this
country that is facing charges should
automatically go filed to run for
president
because why if you're going to let that
orange turd do it then everybody
if they can do it to him they can do it
to us yeah exactly I love that too you
know they're only they're only coming
after they're coming after you but
Trump's in the way let me tell you
something my daughter could stomp him
like a narc at a biker rally and I
guarantee it guarantee it
well here's that video you were talking
about that he reposted it's not very
long you repost this it's maga.com on on
fraud social and he retrieved it and
it's the dumbest um way to say that you
reposted something but here it is listen
really closely you [__] around with
us if you do something bad to us we are
going to do
things to you that have never been done
before it's hard to hear it because they
put that stupid music over to make him
sound cool but he says if you [__] with
us if you do anything to us then we'll
do much more [__] to you or whatever is
that real Is that real audio or is that
a guy I don't know he's the worst
mobster ever yeah right it is the worst
mobster ever he is he brought mob to the
White House and you know what at the end
of the day I'm at the point now and I'm
like you know what [__] it let's do it
let's do it if you [__] want to
really go
because make no mistake about I mean I
mean look look at these pieces of [__] I
mean right now freaking Tommy tuberville
is holding up friggin the promotions the
friggins let me tell you something you
know usually it's it is you know uh
unanimous votes and the reason why is
because by the time a person gets up to
that level where you are now in the
general officer ranks you already have a
a history of being squared away getting
[__] done you know you're you're you
know you're probably a uh photographic
memory I mean that's how these people
are it doesn't mean that they're perfect
but for the most part when a person gets
to that level it's always unanimous you
know vote because you can't really argue
because they have such an impressive
background remember we got a lot of
people in the military and when you go
up the up to the pyramid the people at
the top top that are generals make no
mistake about it they got their [__]
together they are wired tight so you
know I mean this jackass is going to do
that so don't tell me and if you support
what Tommy tuberville is don't you ever
tell me that you support veterans you
know these are the [__] that will
knock down their grandmother and get a
picture of a veteran getting off a plane
coming back from a combat zone but then
they want to do kind of stupid [__]
like this because they say the Army is
woke let me tell you something how did
you know that how do you know the Army's
woke because your candy ass ain't never
picked up a rifle a man to post you
never signed your name on the dotted
line so how do you know that the
military is woke [__] out of here with
that [__] well and and someone on
Twitch says that video of Donald Trump
uh threatening everyone it sounds
totalitarian to me and that's exactly
the point that's that's the point of the
video that's the point of the video I
don't mean to flip here but this morning
um Gabe Sanchez here he tweeted about
the Barbie movie and I think it's really
funny that they're all really pissed off
about Jason Aldean getting canceled yet
they wanna they wanna cancel the Barbie
movie major I haven't loved it well I
loved it you said you said this you said
uh you love the Barbie movie and when
you watched it you knew exactly why the
Republicans hate it now I have to go
[__] watch it the whole movie I don't
want to I what I will say this I
recommend everyone sees the movie it was
a beautifully executed film with
talented actors a diverse cast very
funny uh it's a good story
and you'll notice if you see the movie
though it's like within the first like
15 minutes like you'll understand
exactly why they're pissed off and then
even beyond that the messaging and the
narrative you're like is there like just
floods of rainbows or some [__] or I
mean they're in Barbie land and everyone
is great and women are strong and
independent
not enough said enough said enough said
and I said well you know what's funny is
Matt gets in his wine did they go to
some kind of Premiere thing for this
movie or something yeah they did right
so they they love this movie and I've
got a I've got a a clip here of his wife
apparently I don't know I I thought I
thought she she I don't know why she's
not in school today but um what
what isn't it
summer break that's why
right she doesn't start her senior year
until uh August okay she's a senior well
and she might be a junior I don't know
but um here she is on uh Steve bannon's
Trader TV News Network and she's talking
about the Barbie movie I I don't know
let's listen
um the feminism kind of streak
throughout the movie was really that men
are completely useless
um I don't know why Ken and Barbie
couldn't have just teamed up to take
over Mattel
um but it is really completely different
than the female empowerment of you know
the the Barbie that you grew up with um
and I grew up with Barbies they they
reflect and help you become the person
that you're gonna be how she treats her
friends how she presents herself in her
fashion outfits having this kind of
Joyful up feeling you know
um kind of ability to do anything and be
anyone and all what the [__] does she
think female empowerment is what
definitely but they are so [__]
they're dumb as dog [__] man all right
he's like I hate this because of the
female empowerment thing and Barbie you
know the Barbie I knew was about female
empowerment like what the [__] are you
talking about which what what do you
want you know what's what's right here
you know what he's gonna sit here and
you're gonna gripe about a movie shows
that women can be strong thank good lord
well I think I think they probably got
really offended and this is nothing that
you know is is revealing any secrets
because they show it in there there's
multiple different Barbies one of which
Issa Rae the actress plays the president
and she happens to be black okay oh and
she's a woman a woman God oh man
so cancel cancel
the funniest thing about this it's a
[__] movie it's made up about a toy
or multiple toys
and no one is forcing them to see it no
one no one just like no one forced you
to take the vaccine no one is forcing
you to go see the Barbie movie if you
wait wait I I heard I heard that they're
making all all white people they're
making them they're they're bussing them
uh to the theaters to make them sit down
and they're holding their eyes open and
they're tying their hands into the
chairs that's what I heard I mean that's
right that might be in some on some of
these woke liberal states but I can tell
you I went to a theater last night and
every one of a variety of backgrounds
ages races genders whatever
laughing laughing but you mean you mean
this movie has humor in it too not just
female empowerment how dare they how
dare they couple things
just wokeism just wokeism everywhere
there's a there's a monologue in that
movie like near the end of the uh the
second act right because that's you've
got three act movie and and the third
Act is where they begin to like
fix this problem at the end of the
second act is where this monologue is
given and I can guarantee at that point
Republicans are going to be [__]
livid because it talks about what women
are and what their expectation are and
what they can be and what they can be so
they're not gonna be very happy and and
that just and but here's the sad part is
that these dumbass Trump balloons on the
Republican side that are females are
going to deny their children the ability
to go watch a movie that shows that
women can be competent and and they're
not going to watch it because of the
[__] that they're hearing from the
right because the right is obviously
going to condemn this picture because it
shows that women have the ability to get
[__] done right so yeah so their whole
argument now is they're trying to say
that it's a communist film that's the
best they can come up with call me
Barbie call me Barbie I like it one more
one more clip before we go and the
reason why is because this ad that March
Taylor green cut for Joe Biden did you
see this uh major where Marjorie Taylor
green endorsed endorsed all the ideas
that Joe Biden all the work that Joe
Biden's been doing to not only not only
to to advance what FDR started and LBJ
but to con to finish it to finish off to
finish off education to finish off make
sure that rule poverty is done you
haven't seen this ad you haven't seen
this ad oh my gosh well we're gonna have
to show that ad first and then I'll come
back to this other clip here
um I got to show him this ad first
Marjorie Taylor green went on stage to a
turning point USA Nazi rally uh major
and she really thought she she owned Joe
Biden by saying exactly what Joe Biden
had done and his record
um for what he has done since he was
president and she went on stage and she
said these things and you know what the
Biden campaign went you know what I
agree with that um why don't we just cut
an ad with Marjorie Taylor green
endorsing Joe Biden let's listen Joe
Biden had the largest public investment
in Social infrastructure and
environmental programs that is actually
finishing what FDR started that LBJ
expanded on and Joe Biden is attempting
to complete programs to address
education Medical Care Urban problems
rural poverty Transportation Medicare
Medicaid labor unions and he still is
working on it
those are her real words you really you
really thought that that was she really
thought that was a burn major
um but you know what that's this is how
these people operate they really do
truly believe that it is a bad thing
that Joe Biden is finishing what FDR
started here's Joe Biden's response
today in Philadelphia here's his
response to that ad let's listen to the
president of the United States
as you may have seen apparently 40
million people watched Marjorie Taylor
green the very conservative Channel lady
from the state of Georgia
said Biden is doing things like
Roosevelt
and and it goes on the line as if it's
creating these jobs and he thinks that
I never had an endorsement from
originally
he's never had an endorsement from her
before so so you're telling me she
actually that's not a that's not a
made-up clip no no she said it let me
she was like I'm gonna own the libs with
this one you're kidding me
can you find me the actual clip of her
saying this [__] on stage she actually
said this [__] she thought she was
burning him too she's like oh he's
trying to do socialism like Medicare
Medicaid education Transportation you
know them [__] highways them
socialists call me [__] asphalt
highways
bastard I'm serious she said that [__] I
I mean not even my words but then hers
hilarious let me see if I can find um I
said are you oh you got it okay yeah
here here is the um here's the original
clip this is the original clip of
Marjorie Taylor green saying it on stage
at turning points USA and you can tell
uh from the ad you know the ads a little
shorter than her Diddy here but they did
not change her words and what she's
saying listen Linda Johnson is very
similar to Joe Biden how are they the
same they're both Democrat socialist
Lyndon B Johnson was the majority leader
in the Senate does that sound familiar
he was vice president to Kennedy Joe was
vice president to Obama okay
disappointed as the president after JFK
was assassinated then he was elected
okay his big socialist programs were the
Great Society the Great Society were big
government programs to address education
yeah medical care or Urban problems
poverty Transportation Medicare Medicaid
food stamps and Welfare the office of
Economic Opportunity and Big labor and
Labor Union Yes unions are good LBJ had
the Great Society but Joe Biden had
build back better yes he did he still is
working on it he sure is largest
and social infrastructure and
environmental programs God damn right
he's actually finishing what FDR started
that LBJ expanded on and Joe Biden is
attempting to complete he probably will
meanwhile we are now 32 trillion dollars
in debt with record high homelessness
40-year record inflation we're losing
the U.S dollar as the number one world
currency we're losing our freedoms our
government is one big fat bloated
machine
and it's killing the American dream
tax cuts I don't I don't I don't know I
don't know what she thinks the American
dream is but all that stuff she listed
that FDR and LBJ and Joe Biden's trying
to finish that's the [__] people think
of when you think American dream and let
me tell you that I don't want to hear
her talk about friggin anything
especially poverty and things like that
when she spent a hundred thousand
dollars on a friggin used tube of
chapstick from Kevin McCarthy and you
can't tell me that those two ain't that
gone secretly going behind the freaking
deck on you know the the the doors and
the yeah hooking up because I'm gonna
tell right now nobody spends a hundred
thousand dollars
and not only that but also it was a
hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars in PPP loan like don't talk
about welfare and assistance hey hey hey
hey when when rich white folk get get
theirs that's not welfare okay all right
yeah I I want my rich white welfare
that's why I don't want you to have your
poor Brown welfare okay that get that
straight get that straight that's what
they mean that's what they mean Richard
major I'm glad you joined us I'm glad
you popped in here at the last moment
give give us a Shameless plug before we
go here where can we I I you know I do
my nightly lives at oh Jetta Live on
YouTube and Facebook and I have just
started the turn
leftpack.org and we're going to stick it
to Doug on these [__] I'm gonna go
in their backyards and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be in Josh Holly's backyard Kevin
McCarthy we're gonna we're gonna start
putting some some boots in these
people's ass well you know Josh Holly's
backyard is my backyard so let's talk uh
off air my friend let's do it everyone
boots man Lucas Koontz let's let's talk
off air my friend and uh everybody
follow follow major here watch his show
go look at the pack uh check it out
major I'm glad you popped in thanks for
joining us we'll talk to you soon my
friend Airborne thanks guys
uh what a great show today had two
guests Fred Wellman major popped in we
watched a lot of Clips we had a lot of
fun we we listened to the Tennessee
Brando video uh new music video now hard
on for Hunter you guys got to go check
it out
um so everybody make sure make sure
right now that you subscribe to the Tony
Michael's podcast because you're not
going to want to miss content like this
this is content that you're not going to
want to miss so hit subscribe on the
YouTube channel right now and as you
leave the show don't leave yet but as
you leave hit the like button if you
haven't already I'm trying to get better
at this YouTube hit the like button hit
the like buttons
also go to the twitch Channel if you can
do that too for me follow us on Twitch
at twitch.tv Tony Michaels it's free to
follow us on Twitch if you have a Prime
account you can link your Prime account
to your Twitch account and get a free
subscription with Amazon gaming the
directions are at D Tony michaels.com
just go there the other thing you can
find at the tonymichaels.com is our
Facebook link because you can watch us
there every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
for Tuple hours at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and also don't forget to
download do not forget to download every
single episode apples
Spotify and Google you got to get the
audio version of every single one it's
super important that you download it for
us so we get in the rankings also
tonight we're gonna have the bonehead of
the week pole bone head of the week so
don't forget to follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you can also vote on
YouTube another reason to hit the
Subscribe button while you're here right
now Gabe Sanchez do you have a what was
that coming as well I do I do I'm I'm
going to be wrapping up the what was
that on Marjorie Taylor green the rap
video I because I saw the Barbie movie I
definitely have to go after Ted Cruz
Matt Gates and all these other
Republicans who think that this movie is
some woke [__] propaganda communist
nonsense great I have to do it will I
head up RFK Jr I might I might slap that
[__] just might do it just might do it
so go to what was thatshow.com or go to
patreon.com I am gabejances to check out
all the all the although what was that
things that are going on over there also
while you're on patreon.com visit mypage
dude the Tony Michaels the links that
these tonymichaels.com visit that
patreon page as well I can't wait for
tomorrow we got bone head of the week
it's Friday Friday Friday
going into the weekend I'm gonna go see
the Barbie movie I think tomorrow
well I got two now because you're like
uh Republicans hate it you know either
you know I love [__] that Republicans
say movie like look look I'm I look
Barbies whatever right I right I
obviously I don't play with Barbies when
you're I have a sister so I never really
played with it I've never seen a Barbie
until my until I had my daughter because
I had a brother and the thing is I would
even tell you that Barbie was a big
thing in the 90s early 2000s right but
then there was a bunch of other scene
like Bratz dolls and all these other
things that came out that were like here
were some other you know female uh toys
that you can play with
and this is probably the first time I'd
seen so much like once they announced
the movie and then they were coming out
with the movie I was like oh okay Barbie
yeah I hadn't really thought about
Barbie in years
and after I saw it I was like ah [__]
man this I don't know I think it's gonna
be I think it's a great movie and yeah I
think Greta Gerwig did an amazing job
with Noah uh bumba to write the movie
She directed the movie The Cast is
phenomenal the story Robbie oh my gosh
oh Margot Robbie's great beautiful Ryan
Gosling uh he's beautiful oh my God man
dude look he's kidding he's kin dude
he's he's summer bod motivation you know
what I'm saying oh there you go there
you go I gotta go see the movie you go
see the movie this weekend if you can
I'll see you tomorrow though tomorrow
Friday bone end of the week
same time same exact [__] place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon
marjorie's got a heart on for Hunter
talks about him all the time
shows off the dick pics of Congress
they drive her out of her mind
she drives like hell to
Hilton racing
she tries like hell to project
[Music]
at least that's what we suspect
Junior has got a hard
for Honor
he always hands him the planet
for all of his dirty feelings
and the time immense wasted
he thinks that we all can't see it
the little twinkle he gets in his eyes
with all the world's problems getting
back on our feet
breaking our backs just to make ends
meet they just can't help it they just
can't stop demanding the sea Hunter's
laptop
they all gone
they're dividing distract
truth won't get in the way of their
stories
they won't be bothered with bags
they all wish that they could have party
but he did back in his face
but they all got a heart on for Hunter
and the truth is they just couldn't hang